John Sparks reports from caraman marash
the epicenter of the earthquake and a
warning this report does show images of
people who have died
The Heart Of This Disaster lies at the
end of the road in a mountain city
called karaman marash
the fault line ruptured underneath their
feet forcing tens of thousands into
plastic tents
but they have managed to survive the
Quakes and tremors
when many of their neighbors have not
they call this area the Abra District
it's home to a series of apartment
buildings but nine blocks have been
ripped from their foundations
their occupants buried in disorderly
tombs
we saw volunteers clambering over the
concrete looking for signs of life
but the bodies of those who have lost
their lives were visible between the
cracks
when the volunteers find a mattress when
they find a bed
they know they're likely to find a body
as well because the earthquake struck at
night and most people were asleep
and I think they found another body here
[Applause]
further up we heard a tortured cry from
the man on the left
the volunteers had found the body of his
12 year old daughter wrapped in a
blanket which had laid on her bed
she was carried down the slope by her
uncle as he called out her name
cried
have you checked to see if she's alive
or not do you know if she's alive
the girl had passed away
we found her father called Juma actop
and he wanted to say a few words how do
you feel now I'm sure that you have been
looking for her since the earthquake
strike
foreign
friends and relatives gathered near the
rubble hoping for something like a
miracle but they were also angry the
first excavator had only just arrived
[Music]
some are trying volunteers and others
who think the residents at Abra still
have a chance at life
and we were taken to see a Survivor
there's a person in this van who has
just been rescued has just been pulled
out of the rubble so we're going to try
and have a word
Mustafa spent two days in the rubble and
he thinks many residents could have been
rescued
foreign
[Music]
gathered in front of block a they could
see their relatives through a slit in
the concrete but they couldn't crawl
inside
this woman couldn't hide her distress
my brother was alive for 15 hours and
nobody came to help us my brother was
alive she says
the Turkish government says it's doing
everything it can the rescue operation
is improving every day
but this city at the epicenter is
struggling to cope with grief and
devastation
John Sparks Sky News
foreign